You know what the key is to these cold opens? You just start talking and stuff just tumbles out of the mouth. It's halfway interesting. Go ahead, Will, give it a shot. Just start yammering. Oh man, taxis in this year really got me in knots. That's pretty good. Thanks man. That's pretty good stuff. You think that's good? Wait till this all new Smartless.
你知道这些冷开场的关键是什么吗？你就是开始说话，然后东西自然而然地从嘴里蹦出来。挺有意思的。来吧，威尔，试一下。就随便瞎扯吧。天哪，今年的出租车真让我头疼。这挺不错的。谢谢老兄。这东西挺不错的。你觉得这不错？等着看这档全新的Smartless吧。
Nice. Welcome to Smartless. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less.
不错。欢迎收听Smartless。Smart。Less。Smart。Less。Smart。Less。
Smart. Less. Well, where are you? I'm in the office. I'm in the office. I'm in the office. I'm in the office. I'm in the office.
Smart。Less。嗯，你在哪？我在办公室。我在办公室。我在办公室。我在办公室。我在办公室。
I'm in the office. I'm in the office. I'm in the office. I'm in the office. I'm in the office. I'm in the office. I'm in the office. Well, where are you? I'm at home now. I know. Why did you switch places? Because I was at my office as they were doing work here. Oh, that's right.
我在办公室。我在办公室。我在办公室。我在办公室。我在办公室。我在办公室。我在办公室。嗯，你在哪？我现在在家。我知道。你为什么换地方？因为我呆在办公室时，他们在那边施工。哦，对哦。
Oh, that's right. Remember the office, Sean? Yeah, that was extraordinary. Yeah, that lasted for just one recording. And now he's away from that work site. Ruh! Yeah. You know, it's so funny, you just have such a funny thing.
哦，对哦。还记得那个办公室吗，肖恩？对，那真是非同寻常。对，那只维持了一次录制。现在他已经离开那个施工现场了。鲁！对。你知道，太搞笑了，你就是有这么一种搞笑的特质。
Don't make me go deep on this. Your thing about work, you think that you go to office. Hey, I'm actor, my new role is work. Look at his, look at him. Again, I grew up, I did everything I could to not do that. Right, you know what I mean? You nailed it. You don't want to step behind a desk.
别让我深究这个。你关于工作的那个梗，你觉得你去办公室。嘿，我是演员，我的新角色就是工作。看他，看他。再说一次，我长大了，我尽我所能不去那样做。对吧，你知道我的意思吗？你抓到精髓了。你才不想坐在办公桌后面呢。
Yeah. Yeah. Right? That's my dad, I mean, God bless him. Yeah, but we all sit behind desks during the day. Yes. I mean, right? We did everything.
对。对。对吧？那就是我爸，我是说，上帝保佑他。对，但我们白天都坐在办公桌后面。对。我是说，对吧？我们什么都做过。
No, not Will. Not me. Will sits on the couch and he watches the Toronto Maple Leafs win. Sure do. That's all he does. Oh, look at that. I tell you who captures the camera real well
不，威尔没有。我没有。威尔坐在沙发上，看多伦多枫叶队赢球。我当然是。他就会这个。哦，你看那个。我跟你说谁特写镜头抓得特别好
is that Brendan Shanahan. He sure does, doesn't he? When they point that camera at him up in that power box. Yeah. I know. He's stuck there looking like the boss he is. He's turned into a real silver fox, hasn't he? Yeah, Cameron loves him.
就是那个布伦丹·沙纳汉。他确实是，对吧？当他们把镜头对准他在那个包厢里的时候。对。我知道。他坐在那儿，看起来就像个大老板。他变成了一只真正的银狐，不是吗？对，卡梅伦可喜欢他了。
By the way, he's going gonna call me and be like, what do you mean silver? You've got gray hair. It's a salt and pepper fox. Silver fox in a power box. I know. How about the time that he tried to teach Sean, Sean asked Shani when he was in town last year
顺便说一句，他会打电话给我，问，你是什么意思，什么银狐？你明明是白头发。那是椒盐色的狐狸。包厢里的银狐。我知道。还有那次他试图教肖恩，肖恩去年在城里时问沙尼
to teach him how to fight at the Beverly Hills Hotel out the back door and Sean went at him. And he's like, okay, well, and Shani's laughing. Yeah, in two seconds he grabbed his shirt. Yeah, and Sean was saying, wait, aren't you supposed to take this off me? Isn't this shirt supposed to come off? I thought it was shirts against skins. I thought we were doing shirts against skins.
教他在比弗利山庄酒店后门怎么打架，然后肖恩就冲向他。他就像是，好吧，然后沙尼笑了。对，两秒钟他就被抓住衬衫了。对，然后肖恩说，等等，你不是应该帮我脱掉这个吗？这件衬衫不是应该脱掉吗？我还以为是光膀子打赤膊呢。我还以为我们在玩光膀子打赤膊。
By the way, in high school, didn't you fear, well, hey Will, in high school, didn't you? Sean, that hurts. Now you're on board, thank you Sean. In high school, didn't it freak you out, or junior high, when the coach would say, okay, we're gonna do shirts and skins, and like in basketball or whatever. I would always.
顺便说一句，在高中时，你难道不害怕，嗯，嘿，威尔，在高中时，你难道不……肖恩，那很痛。现在你加入我们了，谢谢你，肖恩。在高中时，或者初中时，当教练说，好了，我们要光膀子打赤膊了，比如在打篮球什么的，难道不让你觉得毛骨悚然吗？我总是……
I didn't wanna take my shirt off. I didn't wanna take my shirt off. I was always afraid of that. It's traumatizing. Why do they do that to kids? And then they made us take showers, and like 12, 13 years old. I'm like, I don't want to do that.
我不想脱掉衬衫。我不想脱掉衬衫。我一直很害怕那个。这太让人精神创伤了。他们为什么要对小孩子做这种事？然后他们还让我们洗澡，才12、13岁的时候。我就想，我才不要那样。
I know. Will likes walking around with his kid off, just kind of shaking his trunk all over the place. I never went to, I never stepped foot into a gym until I was about 24. So I was never like- Oh really? Yeah, ever.
我知道。威尔喜欢光着身子走来走去，到处晃荡他的大肚子。我从来没去过，我直到24岁左右才踏入健身房一步。所以我从来没有……哦，真的吗？对，从来没有。
Yeah, but you played sports. But I played sports, but I was, I just inched, yeah, ever. Yeah, but you played sports. I played sports, but I was, I just never, and then, but I went to boarding school, so I had to take showers, you know, starting at age 12 when I went to boarding school. Yeah, it's so like, I can't. Yeah, it was, it's weird. I went to camp once, I think I said this,
对，但你玩体育。但我玩体育，但我，我只是勉强，对，从来没有。对，但你玩体育。我玩体育，但我，我只是从不，然后，但我上的是寄宿学校，所以我得洗澡，你知道的，从12岁上寄宿学校开始。对，这太……我受不了。对，这很……这很诡异。我曾经去过一次夏令营，我想我说过这个，
and we had a line up outside, a music camp, Blue Lake Fine Arts Camp in Michigan, and- Not a sports camp, Blue Lake Fine Arts Camp in Michigan. And they made a little. Not a sports camp. No. Huh, hang on, let me just, let me just adjust everything I know about you. Ha ha ha ha ha ha. And they made us line up outside to take a shower
我们在外面排队，一个音乐夏令营，密歇根州的蓝湖艺术夏令营，然后……不是体育夏令营，密歇根州的蓝湖艺术夏令营。他们弄了一个……不是体育夏令营。不。呃，等等，让我……让我调整一下我对你所有的认知。哈哈哈哈哈。然后他们让我们在外面排队洗澡
in front of, and one by one, we had to take a shower. And you had to like, take your clothes off in front of all of these by one, we had to take a shower. And you had to like take your clothes off in front of all of these kids, your peers, and it was so awful. Sean, when I was in seventh grade, age 12, I went from living with my folks to a place where they had four showers per side in a big, huge open room with no divider.
在一个……一个接一个地，我们必须洗澡。你不得不像这样，在一个接一个地在所有这些……我们必须洗澡。你不得不像这样在所有这些孩子、同龄人面前脱掉衣服，这太糟糕了。肖恩，当我上七年级、12岁的时候，我从和父母住的地方搬到一个地方，那里每边有四个淋浴间，在一个巨大的开放式房间里，没有隔板。
Yeah, that's weird. It's like torture. Yeah, it's awful. And by the way, by the time I got in the camp thing, by the time I got up there, all the hot water was gone. So I was taking a cold shower, and I couldn't breathe. Well, if I'm being honest, you probably needed it. You're showering with all those dudes.
对，这很诡异。这就像折磨。对，这太糟糕了。而且顺便说一句，等我排到去洗澡的时候，热水全都没有了。所以我洗了个冷水澡，我都喘不过气来。好吧，如果说实话，你可能确实需要这个。你和所有那些家伙一起洗澡。
I mean, that probably helped. Just get things back to normal. Anything to calm me down. Yeah. Oh my God. What do you got some electrolytes going there, Sean? This morning? I do, yeah.
我是说，那可能挺有帮助的。只是让事情恢复正常。任何能让我平静下来的东西都可以。哦，天哪。肖恩，你那里有什么电解质饮料吗？今天早上？我有，对。
What happened to the milk? Is the cow dead? No, I had milk already. Oh, you're chasing it with some electrolytes? Good luck on the toy toy. What are you? Jesus, you're so obsessed with people's bell. Well, I just, I don't, he's creating a bomb. That electrolyte's gonna cut right through that milk
牛奶怎么了？牛死了吗？不，我已经喝过牛奶了。哦，你用电解质来顺一顺？祝你在马桶上好运。你是什么？天哪，你对别人的肚子怎么这么着迷。好吧，我只是，我不知道，他在制造一颗炸弹。那电解质会直接切入牛奶里
like a knife. Is it really? Yeah. Is it really? Yeah, dude. Whenever I see people eating, I'm not thinking. Get yourself over a toilet within the next 60 minutes. I'm never thinking about.
就像一把刀一样。真的吗？对。真的吗？对啊，老兄。每当我看到别人吃东西，我都不会去想。准备好在接盘的60分钟内冲向马桶吧。我从来没有想过……
Well, let's wrap this up. Whenever I see people eat, I'm never thinking about, man, that's really gonna come back to haunt them on the toilet. It just doesn't occur to me. You know, when I see clips of that hot sauce talk show, that's all I think about. I know, same.
好吧，我们结束这个话题吧。每当我看到人们吃东西，我从来不会去想，天哪，那真的会在马桶上报复他们的。我根本不会这么想。你知道的，当我看到那个辣酱脱口秀的片段时，我满脑子想的就是这个。我知道，我也是。
What are people doing? Same. You had your mind. No, they should do it from a toilet. Yeah. Yeah. You won't catch me on that show. No, of course not.
人们在搞什么鬼？我也是。你心里想的……不，他们应该在马桶上录制。Yeah。对。你可不会在那个节目上抓到我。不，当然不会。
Not once. No, no, no, of course you won't. Whose guest is it today? Yeah, do you have a narcoleptic guest or something? Will, let's get to it. No, no, no, well, he's a great guest and I was about to get to it and then I was thinking about you talking
一次都没有。不，不，不，你当然不会。今天是谁的嘉宾？对，你是有个嗜睡症嘉宾还是怎么的？威尔，我们开始吧。不，不，不，嗯，他是个很棒的嘉宾，我正要说到他，然后我就想起你刚才在说
about shitting everywhere. But our guest, the only thing, he hasn't shit everywhere. All he's done is he's scored everywhere. This guy has been making everybody laugh. That's another word for it. He has been un, he's been making people shit themselves. He makes me shit myself laughing. He's so fucking funny.
到处拉屎的事。但是我们的嘉宾，唯一的一点是，他没有到处拉屎。他做的一切都是到处大获成功。这家伙让所有人都笑了。这是另一种说法。他一直在把人……让大家笑得屁滚尿流。他把我笑得屁滚尿流。他他妈的太搞笑了。
He's such a great dude. I had the pleasure of kind of getting to know him over the last couple months. He's been very generous as I was going through the process on our film and he has just been, his specials have been unbelievably well received. He's maybe the biggest touring comic out there. His new, his show Tires is about to start
他真是个好家伙。过去几个月我有幸跟他有了点接触。当我经历我们电影的制作过程时，他非常慷慨，而且他的单口喜剧专场反响好得难以置信。他可能是现今巡演规模最大的喜剧演员了。他的新节目《轮胎》马上就要开始
second season on June 5th. He's a great writer, he's an incredible standup, he's the funniest dude. Guys, it's Shane Gillis. Oh, Shane Gillis! You're on Smart List, good morning! Where is he, there he is. Hello! Hey guys, it's Shane Gillis. Oh, Shane Gillis! You're on Smart List, good morning! There he is.
6月5日播出第二季。他是个伟大的编剧，是个了不起的单口喜剧演员，他是最搞笑的家伙。伙计们，他就是肖恩·吉利斯。哦，肖恩·吉利斯！你在《Smart List》上，早上好！他在哪，他就在那。你好！嘿，伙计们，我是肖恩·吉利斯。哦，肖恩·吉利斯！你在《Smart List》上，早上好！他就在那。
Hello! Hey. I love you, this is so cool. Oh, thanks. Easy, easy. Yeah, so funny. Hi, Shane. Hi, Shane, hi, Shane.
你好！嘿。我爱你，这太酷了。哦，谢谢。放轻松，放轻松。对，太搞笑了。嗨，肖恩。嗨，肖恩，嗨，肖恩。
Where do we find you today? Are you wee at home? I am at home, I'm in Austin, Texas. All right, and how is it in Austin? It's all right, it kind of sucks. It's hot and humid a lot. Hot already? I don't fucking, I don't love it. I don't love it.
今天我们在哪里能找到你？你是在家吗？我在家，我在德克萨斯州奥斯汀。好的，奥斯汀现在怎么样？还行吧，有点糟糕。又热又潮湿。已经开始热了吗？我他妈的，我可太不喜欢了。我太不喜欢了。
Yeah, it's hot. It's been hot. It's going to be hot until December. Wow. It's one of the worst places I've ever lived. I hate it. Do you ever jump in that river that they call a lake and cool off a little bit?
对，很热。一直都很热。会一直热到十二月。哇。这是我住过最糟糕的地方之一。我恨死这里了。你有没有跳进他们叫作湖的那个河里去凉快一下？
Yeah, that's very nice. Why do they call it a lake? It does make it snakes around like a river, right? It's literally the Colorado River. I don't know, they call it a lake, I have no idea. Oh, I didn't know that. I didn't know that either. Is that something that happens down there?
对，那挺不错的。他们为什么把它叫作湖？它确实像河一样蜿蜒曲折，对吧？这简直就是科罗拉多河。我不知道，他们叫它湖，我完全不知道。哦，我不知道这个。我也不知道。那是那边常有的事吗？
Yes, it's just the Colorado River. And it doesn't even look like a lake, it's just a river. Yeah. There's just nothing like about it at all. You can throw a rock across it. Wait, so Shane, do you, you live there by choice? I mean, like, it sounds like you hate it. It sounds like you're being forced.
是的，它就是科罗拉多河。它看起来甚至不像个湖，它就是条河。对。它一点也没有湖的样子。你都能拿石头从这头扔到那头。等等，所以肖恩，你，你是自愿住在那里的吗？我的意思是，听起来你很恨它。听起来你像是被逼的。
Like, is there somebody off camera with a gun? Yeah, Joe Rogan. He's right here. He's got a gun to my head. He's down there, right? Yeah, he's down here and he opened a club here and it was either, for a comedian, it's either New York, LA or,
就好像镜头外有人拿枪指着你？对，乔·罗根。他就站在这儿。他拿枪指着我的头。他就在那儿，对吧？对，他就在那儿，他在这里开了一家俱乐部，所以对于喜剧演员来说，要么是纽约、洛杉矶，或者
that was always the only two options and then he opened a club here so you can,, for a comedian it's either New York, LA, or that was always the only two options. And then he opened a club here so you can, you know, you can evade some taxes and do stand-up here. Now he was a stand-up, right? And then I remember he was on one of the greatest shows ever, News Radio, so he was an actor for a minute, right? But he did start a stand-up, didn't he? He's still, I mean, he's done stand-up the entire time.
以前总是只有这两个选择，然后他在这里开了一家俱乐部，所以你可以……对于喜剧演员来说，要么是纽约、洛杉矶，或者以前总是只有这两个选择。然后他在这里开了一家俱乐部，所以你可以，你知道的，你可以逃避一些税收，然后在这里表演单口喜剧。现在他是个单口喜剧演员，对吧？然后我记得他曾出演过史上最伟大的剧集之一《新闻广播室》，所以他曾当过一会儿演员，对吧？但他确实是从单口喜剧开始的，不是吗？他现在仍然，我是说，他一直在做单口喜剧。
And remember Fear Factor? He did Fear Factor. Oh, that Factor? He did Fear Factor. Oh that's right. You should watch that. Fear Factor. So Shane, I first met Shane at Joe's club in Austin. Oh no way. Yeah, I went down there and he was kind enough
还记得《恐慌空间》吗？他做过《恐慌空间》。哦，那个……空间？他做过《恐慌空间》。哦，对哦。你应该去看看那个。《恐慌空间》。所以肖恩，我最初是在乔在奥斯汀的俱乐部认识肖恩的。哦，不会吧。对，我去了那里，他非常友善
and gracious enough to let me have, twice have like 10 minutes of his time on stage. All right Shane, give us a review on Will. No, he doesn't, you don't have to. Yeah, no I want to hear it right now. No, it's going to be, Will doesn't want to hear it. Yeah, no, I want to hear it right now. No, it's going to be, Will doesn't want to hear it because it's flattering. Well, that's what I thought.
也很慷慨，让我在舞台上有两次大概10分钟的时间。好了，肖恩，给我们对威尔作个评价吧。不，他不用，你不用评价。对，不，我马上就想听。不，这会……威尔不想听。对，不，我马上就想听。不，这会……威尔不想听，因为太恭维了。好吧，我也是这么想的。
I was like, so they asked me to help write on this, write some for the movie. And I was like, if I write any material that's good, I need to keep it. You're going to keep it. Because I have nothing. Sure. So, I was like, the only way to do it is
我就想，他们让我帮忙写这个，为电影写一些东西。然后我就想，如果我写了任何好的段子，我得自己留着。你要自己留着。因为我什么都没有。当然。所以，我就想，唯一的办法就是
just to actually do stand up. So, he came down and we did stand up and I was like, he only way to do it is just to actually do stand-up. So he came down and we did stand-up and I was like, he's gonna fucking bomb. This is a lot harder than he thinks. Yeah, so naturally funny right away. I was in the back of the room like, God damn it. He does have, Will you do have that that natural and I mean not as a pejorative, the sort of this ham gene, right? Like you are comfortable with the spotlight on you. I mean, not as a pejorative, sort of this ham gene, right? Like you are comfortable with the spotlight on you. You're comfortable giving a toast, you're comfortable.
去真正地表演单口喜剧。所以，他下来了，我们做了单口喜剧，然后我就想……唯一的办法就是去真正地表演单口喜剧。所以他下来了，我们做了单口喜剧，然后我就想，他他妈的绝对要砸场子。这比他想象的要难得多。对啊，一上去就自然得好笑。我当时在房间后面想，操。他确实有，威尔，你确实有那种天生的——我不是贬义——那种所谓的“戏精基因”，对吧？就是你很享受聚光灯打在自己身上的感觉。我是说，不是贬义，就是那种戏精基因，对吧？就像你很适应聚光灯照着你。你很适应敬酒，你很适应……
I don't have that. I don't like the spotlight on me. I don't like a lot of attention. Will, you're comfortable with it and it puts the audience at ease. It's infectious. Yes, and it's a gift, it's a talent. Shane, you have it too.
我没有那个。我不喜欢聚光灯打在我身上。我不喜欢太多关注。威尔，你很适应这个，这能让观众放松下来。这是有感染力的。是的，这是个天赋，是个才能。肖恩，你也有。
Oh. Well, Shane's gift, it's a talent. Shane, you have it too. Oh. Well, Shane's got, here's the difference. I hemmed my way and hawed my way through it. Shane getting up there is so natural and good. And I know you've been working on it and you've crafted it, but you've got such a great way about you on stage. And you kind of, you bring, what I love is you kind of bring the audience in with you and you laugh and you,
哦。好吧，肖恩的天赋……是个才能。肖恩，你也有。哦。好吧，肖恩有……这里是区别。我是一路支支吾吾、费尽周折才弄出来的。肖恩上去表演就那么自然又出色。我知道你一直在为此努力，你也打磨过，但你在台上有种非常棒的风度。而且你有点……我喜欢的是，你把观众一起带进来，你笑了，然后你……
I don't know, you kind of like, you don't really like take sides. You kind of like, you play to a wide audience, you play to different parts of what people, and you get to kind of just what's funny. So no matter where you land on any subject, you're like, you got to admit that's funny, whether you're talking about politics or whatever it is.
我不知道，你有点像……你真的不怎么选边站。你有点像，你面向广大观众表演，你迎合人们的不同观点，然后你直奔搞笑的核心。所以无论你在任何话题上持什么立场，你都会想，你得承认这很有趣，无论你是在谈论政治还是其他什么。
And I'm sure that that's not, I'm sure that's a skill, right? Like to be able to do that, that's something you kind of work on? I mean, I think it's kind of, I mean, yeah, it's a skill, I guess, but it's also like, that's kind of how I feel most of the time. I don't like picking a side on, I don't know,
而且我确信这并非……我确信这是一项技能，对吧？能够做到这一点，这是你需要努力磨炼的东西吗？我是说，我觉得这有点……我是说，是的，这算是一种技能吧，我猜，但这也像是……这基本上是我平时的真实感受。我不喜欢选边站……
publicly picking a side on an issue typically comes back to make you look like a fucking idiot. Yeah. Yeah, yeah. I don't know, I mean, unless it's like a glaring thing you should support, whatever. But I want to go back to the Austin thing. So the first show we went up and it was fine.
公开在一个议题上选边站通常最后只会让你看起来像个他妈的白痴。对。对，对。我不知道，我是说，除非这是一个你应该支持的显而易见的事情，什么的。但我想回到奥斯汀的事情上。所以第一场演出我们上台了，还算过得去。
The second show we did like an hour later it was great. And it was really frustrating how good you were at it. Oh, with Will, yeah, yeah. And he was reading a script and it was still funny. He was using your material though. No, he wasn't. They did it themselves. In fact, I read the material first and I was like,
第二场演出我们在大约一小时后开始，效果棒极了。而且你在这方面表现得这么好，真的让人挺抓狂的。哦，对威尔来说，对，对。而且他当时还在读稿子，结果还是很好笑。不过他用的是你的素材。不，他没有。他们自己搞定的。事实上，我先看了那些素材，然后我就想，
I don't think this is gonna fucking work. So wait, so what type of, what type? I didn't want to say anything. What was Will's style? Was he like telling stories or was he kind of going joke to joke to joke? It was more storytelling, but it was, it was exactly how I like the standup.
我觉得这他妈的行不通。等等，所以是什么类型的，什么类型的？我本来不想说什么。威尔的风格是什么？他是像在讲故事，还是一个接一个地抛笑梗？更像是讲故事，但它是……这正是我喜欢的单口喜剧风格。
It was stories with jokes, with jokes within it, which was. Do you remember any of it, Willie? Or have you deleted the files? Can you give us a taste? No, well, a lot of it, as Shane knows, he read it because a lot of it is stuff that we use in the film, so we're working on it. So it's various stages of.
它是带有故事性的，故事里面夹杂着笑梗，这……你还记得其中的任何内容吗，威利？还是你已经把文件删了？能让我们先睹为快吗？不，嗯，很多，正如肖恩所知，他读过这些，因为很多都是我们在电影里用到的东西，所以我们还在创作中。所以它处于不同的阶段……
Yeah, because we didn't say it. This is the film that you just shot and that's coming out later this year. What's it called, Will, the film? Is This Thing On. Is This Thing, the film? Is This Thing On. Is This Thing On. Yeah. Is This Thing On.
对，因为我们还没说。这就是你刚拍完、今年晚些时候上映的那部电影。叫什么名字来着，威尔，那部电影？《Is This Thing On》（话筒有声音吗）。电影叫《Is This Thing On》？《Is This Thing On》。《Is This Thing On》。对。《Is This Thing On》。
We can get that on a later date when I'm the guest on the show. Yeah. Right. Are you going to book yourself? Oh, sorry. Go ahead, Shane. Sorry. No, we were laughing.
等我以后作为嘉宾上节目时再聊这个吧。对。没错。你要自己给自己预约通告吗？哦，抱歉。请继续，肖恩。抱歉。不，我们刚才在笑。
I was just at the cellar this week and we were laughing because there's a comedian there. His name's Will Sylvance and Will's playing a character on stage. And after the show, he goes on with the comedian and asks questions about the set, and I think he took the set very seriously. It was like, man, I'm really sorry you're going through all that. Oh, really?
我这周刚好在（喜剧细胞）酒窖，我们当时在笑，因为那里有个喜剧演员。他叫威尔·西尔万斯，威尔在台下扮演一个角色。演出结束后，他上台和喜剧演员交流，问了一些关于演出套路的问题，我觉得他把那个套路太当真了。就好像，天哪，我很抱歉你经历了这一切。哦，真的吗？
That's great. That's a script, you idiot. He did, the first time I did New Joke Monday over there around the corner with him, and he comes up on stage and he asks you questions, and he was like, ooh, like Shane said, he was like, ah, it's not really rough, and I just kind of answered him as if it was all real,
太棒了。那是剧本，你个白痴。他确实……第一次我在那儿的转角处参加“新笑话星期一”时，他上台来问你问题，然后就像……正如肖恩所说，他就像是，哦，感觉不太顺利，然后我就直接当成全是真事回答了他，
and he's like, hang in there, buddy. Yeah, yeah. And we will be right back. And now, back to the show. Wait, Shane, so doing what you do for a living, do you wake up and go to sleep constantly thinking of like, I got it, like, that was funny today, this is funny, well, I got to write that down.
然后他说，坚持住，老兄。对，对。我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目中。等等，肖恩，以你的职业为生，你会不会一醒来和入睡时脑子里都在不停地想：我懂了——今天那个挺好笑，这个也挺好笑，嗯，我得把它记下来。
Like, do you ever get out of that or you were always in that mode? Yeah, I would say yeah, although I don't know I used to be a lot better at it now. I'm kind of just I Should be like that and I'm not okay. I got right on that I got to go back to only thinking about stand-up. Okay for real Yeah, yeah, I mean otherwise I don't know I you feel like you're not coming up with any new material Well, then how do you do what you do?
这种状态你 कभी 会跳出来吗，还是说你一直处于这种模式？对，我会说是的，虽然我不知道我以前在这方面做得好得多。现在我基本上只是……我本该如此，但我并没有。好吧，我得马上行动起来，我得回到只想着单口喜剧的状态中去。好吧，说真的。对，对，不然的话，我觉得你根本想不出任何新素材。好吧，那你是怎么做你现在做的事的？
Do you set aside some time to really focus on work? No, I don't really write that much. I just kind of, I go, this could be a good idea, and then I go on stage and try it. And if I get it, great. So you just figure it out on stage, and it's all straight improv that you haven't really worked on any of it?
你会专门留出一些时间来真正专注于工作吗？不，我其实不怎么写东西。我只是觉得，这可能是个好主意，然后我就上台去试试。如果效果好，那就太棒了。所以你全是在台上现挂想出来的，完全是纯即兴，你根本没怎么排练过？
No, I mean, yeah, you do that for like, like I'll do, if I did stand up tonight, I would do basically 10 minutes that I know I'm, I know. But I just know every word to it. And then I'd maybe try five minutes and see what happens and probably abandon it and then have one of my friends in like four or five months go, hey, that was a funny idea and then I'll try it again.
不，我是说，对，你会那样做，比如我经常会……如果我今晚去表演单口喜剧，我基本上会讲10分钟我知道的、我有把握的内容。但我只是对每个词都烂熟于心。然后我可能会尝试5分钟新东西，看看效果如何，然后可能会放弃它，接着过四五个月后，我的某个朋友会说，嘿，那是个挺有趣的创意，然后我就会再试一次。
And so when you're putting together an hour like to do a Netflix special, like, you know, are you, is that something like that they set the date for and they go, hey man, we need you to deliver this special by this date and so then that's when you kind of hone in and start working on actual stuff or I think they do that sometimes I told them I didn't really I wouldn't want to date on it maybe in 2026 because I got I got a right now I'm doing arenas and I don't think the best way to work an hour out
所以当你在筹备一个小时的演出——比如为了录制Netflix专场时，你知道的，那是不是他们定好日期然后说，嘿，老兄，我们需要你在这个日期前交出这个专场，然后你才会集中精力开始创作真正的内容，还是……我想他们有时会这样做。我告诉过他们我其实……我不想定具体日期，也许定在2026年吧，因为我……我现在在体育馆做巡演，我不觉得打磨一小时内容的最佳方式
is in an arena it's just it's just different I don't know I think I'll do arenas for maybe the next, for the rest of this year and then go down back to clubs and really try to focus on hammering out the hour that I'm doing right now. I don't want to rush, it was special. When did you start? I love, I mean, you've got so much good stuff
是在体育馆里，那感觉完全不同，我不知道。我想我今年剩下的时间都会在体育馆巡演，然后回到俱乐部，真正专注于打磨我目前正在创作的一个小时的内容。我不想匆忙推出一个专场。你什么时候开始的？我喜欢……我是说，你有那么多精彩的内容
that you talk about growing up. I love all that stuff about going to Notre Dame Games with your family. Yeah, that's my favorite. When you guys get in the van together and all that stuff about going to Notre Dame games with your family. Yeah, that's my favorite. When you guys get in the van together and all that stuff. Yeah, yeah, yeah. You've got such rich and your cousins and your family, you've just got such great rich stuff.
都是关于你成长经历的。我太喜欢所有那些跟你家人一起去圣母大学比赛的事了。对，那是我的最爱。当你们一起挤上面包车，还有所有那些关于跟你家人一起去圣母大学比赛的事。对，那是我的最爱。当你们一起挤上面包车，还有所有那些事。对，对，对。你的经历太丰富了，还有你的表亲们和你的家人，你拥有如此精彩丰富的素材。
When, what was the first moment, this is like the question, like how did you start in comedy? But like, when did you start going like, oh, the stories that I'm telling about my family or the shit that's going on, people are laughing enough that I should go to a club and tell it in front of other people. Like, what was that?
什么时候，第一个瞬间是什么时候——这就像那个经典问题：你是怎么开始做喜剧的？但究竟是什么时候，你开始觉得：哦，我讲的关于我家庭的故事，或者身边发生的破事，大家笑得够大声，我应该去俱乐部在其他人面前讲讲。那是个怎样的时刻？
Yeah, I was washing dishes at my friend's restaurant, and I always thought I was funny, and I just had no idea how to get into stand-up. And then one of the cooks was like, I'm gonna go do an open mic at the Harrisburg Comedy Zone tonight. And I was like, oh, you can just do stand-up? And he was like, yeah'm going to go do an open mic at the Harrisburg Comedy Zone tonight. And I was like, oh, you can just do stand up? And he was like, yeah.
对，我当时在朋友的餐厅洗盘子，我一直觉得自己挺搞笑的，但我完全不知道怎么进入单口喜剧圈。然后其中一个厨师说：“我今晚要去哈里斯堡喜剧地带参加开放麦。”然后我就想：“哦，单口喜剧是可以直接去表演的吗？”然后他说：“对啊。”
So I went and I watched and I thought everyone sucked and I was like, I can do that. And then I went back every week for like two months just watching and then I finally got on stage and I fucking bombed. I was like, I don't have to write any material, I'm just funny. I just got up there and couldn't talk.
于是我去了，坐在台下看，我觉得每个人都烂透了，心想：这我上我也行。然后接下来的两个月里，我每周都去观摩，最后终于上台了，结果我他妈的砸得稀烂。我当时想：我根本不用写任何素材，我天生就搞笑。结果我一上台连话都说不出来。
It was crazy how bad it was. And yeah, then it stopped for a while after that, traumatic experience, but I always still wanted to do it. And then eventually I went back and really applied myself and tried and did it. And were you studying to do anything else? Like was this always the career plan or did this derail something else?
那感觉太疯狂了，简直糟透了。然后，经历过那次惨痛的经历后，我停了一阵子，但心里一直还是想做。最后我还是回去了，真正付出了努力，去尝试并坚持了下来。你当时还在为做别的什么做准备吗？这从一开始就是你的职业规划，还是说它打乱了你原本的别的计划？
No, it wasn't really. I was at Westchester University in Pennsylvania. I was studying to become a history teacher. Oh yeah? Wow. The first, I remember the first show I ever did. I fucking, it was a road, the first time I ever went on the road, it was a hotel outside of Pittsburgh in Mars, Pennsylvania,
不，其实不是。我当时在宾夕法尼亚州的西切斯特大学。我学的是历史教育专业。哦，真的吗？哇。我记得我做过的第一场演出。我他妈的……那是一次巡演，我第一次去外地巡演，那是匹兹堡郊区宾夕法尼亚州马尔斯的一家酒店，
and it was in like a hotel lobby, and I bombed so badly that the club owner took me aside and was like, what are you doing with your life? And I was like, I'm a college student, I'm studying to be a history teacher. He was like, why don't you just do that? Instead of stand up. I was like, alright man.
演出就在类似酒店大堂的地方进行，我砸得太惨了，以至于俱乐部老板把我拉到一边问我：“你到底在过怎样的人生？”我说：“我是一名大学生，我正在学历史教育。”他说：“那你为什么不直接去干那个？别搞什么单口喜剧了。”我说：“好吧，老兄。”
I kind of took it to heart. Were you done with your set yet? I swear to God it was in between shows. I still had another set. I had to go up there like, this might be it. This is my retirement. You know who loves history? Our host Will Arnett. Yeah, lives for it.
我真的把这话听到心里去了。你当时演出还没结束吧？我发誓，那正是在两场表演的间隙。我还有另一场要演。我不得不硬着头皮上台想：这可能就是我的谢幕演出。这是我的退休仪式。你知道谁热爱历史吗？我们的主持人威尔·阿奈特。对，他简直为历史而生。
Specifically World War II history. What's your favorite? You like the European or the American? He knows it all, man. Right, Shane, you know it all. Well, I don't know. I like World War II. I like American Civil War is great.
特别是二战历史。你最喜欢哪个？你喜欢欧洲战场还是美国战场？他全都知道，老兄。对吧，肖恩，你什么都知道。嗯，我不知道。我喜欢二战。美国内战也很棒。
Yeah, right. Have you seen both the Civil War documentary and the World War II documentary that Ken Burns did? Yeah. I love them both. Yeah, yeah. I like the Civil War one.
对，没错。你看过肯·伯恩斯拍的《内战》纪录片和《二战》纪录片吗？看过。两部我都超爱。对，对。我更喜欢《内战》那部。
I like better. It's so powerful. The West, Vietnam is great. His Vietnam documentary was great. Yeah. Yeah. Because I didn't know shit about Vietnam. I remember, what did you say about the Ken Burns documentary?
我更喜欢那部。太有震撼力了。《西部风云》，还有《越南战争》也很棒。他的《越南战争》纪录片太棒了。对。因为我对越南战争一无所知。我记得，你对肯·伯恩斯的纪录片是怎么说的？
You said that it's literally kryptonite for women? Yeah. Yeah. If you put it on, they're going to fall asleep. Yeah. I remember you used to talk, the other thing that really made me laugh, you used to talk about that dude Shelby Foot, that historian, and the way that he would, right?
你说这简直是女人的催眠安眠药？对。对。如果你放这个，她们绝对会睡着。对。我还记得你以前常说，另一件让我大笑的事，你以前常说那个叫谢尔比·福特的家伙，那个历史学家，还有他说话的那种方式，对吧？
I did that, I did a bunch of Ken Burns material in my SNL monologue. And everyone was kind of like, what the fuck is he talking about? That was it, that was it. That was hilarious. It was recent, it was recent, right? Yeah, every time my monologue doesn't go great on SNL,
我当时在《周六夜现场》（SNL）的开场独白里用了好多肯·伯恩斯的梗。每个人当时都一脸懵逼：这货他妈的在说啥？就是那样，就是那样。那太爆笑了。那是最近的事，对吧？对，每次我在SNL上的开场独白表现得不够好时，
I'm over two on those things. I loved it. I loved it too. I like it, look, I like it and I'm having fun up there, but it was, Tate McCray was the musical guest. So the audience was like 20 year old. Yeah. Mm-hmm chicks just in the front and I'm up there talking about fucking Shelby foot Just some ogre walked out on the stage and talked about Shelby Foote. They were probably scared.
我在那些事情上的战绩就是零胜两负。我超爱。我也超爱。我喜欢，听着，我喜欢，我在台上玩得很开心，但那是……泰特·麦克雷是音乐嘉宾。所以台下全是一群20岁的……对。嗯哼，辣妹们就坐在最前排，而我却在台上滔滔不绝地讲着他妈的谢尔比·福特。一个活生生的食人魔走到台上去大谈谢尔比·福特。她们大概吓坏了吧。
You literally referenced the Battle of Fredericksburg. Shrek. Yeah. Hey, so with such a drastic, are you happy with where you're at? You find yourself at the top of your career in this particular field. At such a young age.
你居然提到了弗雷德里克斯堡战役。像个怪物一样。嘿，经历了这么巨大的转变，你对现在的自己满意吗？你发现自己在这个特定的领域达到了事业的巅峰。在这么年轻的时候。
Which is drastically different than this other path that you thought you would be on. Like, have you adapted? Like, are you digging it? Right. It's, I don't know, you guys probably know what it's like. It's kind of uncomfortable. There's definitely some weird parts to it.
这和你之前设想的另一条人生道路有着天壤之别。你适应了吗？你觉得现在这样过瘾吗？对。这……我不知道，你们大概也知道这是什么感觉。其实挺不自在的。里面绝对有一些很诡异的部分。
Yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah. It's pretty uncomfortable, you know, with the imposter syndrome and depression and all that, but, you know, I just drink a lot, so that helps. Yeah, around the edges. That really fucking makes things easier, you know? When you break up, you go off.
对。对，对，对。挺不自在的，你知道的，伴随着冒名顶替综合征、抑郁症之类的一切，但是，你知道的，我就是狂喝酒，所以这挺有帮助的。对，在边缘地带。这他妈的确实让事情好过多了，你知道吧？当你崩溃时，你就爆发了。
We all have the option to just sort of get off the highway and like, you know, hide, I guess. And you know, everyone forgets about you after a few years anyway, get off the highway and hide, I guess. And everyone forgets about you after a few years anyway, so we could find anonymity if we wanted it. Like, did you have that moment, I remember when you take, in your case, stand-up gigs or specials or whatever,
我们所有人其实都有选择，可以随时从这条高速公路上开下去，然后，你知道的，找个地方躲起来。反正过几年大家也都会把你忘光，从高速公路上下来躲起来，我猜。反正过几年大家都会把你忘光，所以如果我们想要隐姓埋名的话，随时都能找到。你有过那种时刻吗，我记得当你经历……就你而言，单口喜剧巡演、专场或者别的什么，
in my case it was a sitcom, and you. This guy! We love that joke! It was, and the first time that it started, I took it because it was a job, right? You audition, you're just looking for a job, and then you have no idea what's going to happen. You're just looking to feed yourself, and then you become famous.
对我的情况来说是一部情景喜剧，然后你……这小子！我们太爱这个梗了！当时的情况是，第一次它开始火的时候，我接下它只是因为它是一份工作，对吧？你去试镜，你只是在找一份工作，然后你根本不知道会发生什么。你只是想填饱肚子，然后你就突然成名了。
It's like, oh! By accident almost, right? You just kind of want to work as an actor. It's not like, I want to be famous, I just want to work. And then it happens, and then in the moment, and I remember thinking, I'm like, oh, this is what, this is what I read about, this is what I watch TV and this happens.
就好像，哦！几乎是出于意外，对吧？你只是想作为演员好好工作。并不是说，我想出名，我只是想工作。然后它发生了，然后在那个当下，我记得当时我在想，哦，这就是……这就是我以前在书上读到的、看电视时发生的那种情况。
So did that happen to you in that, do you remember that moment where you're like, oh shit, this is what it feels like to kind of become successful? Yeah, there was definitely some moments along the way. I mean, hosting SNL when I did that, that was one of those moments because I had gotten fired from the show before
所以这种事也在你身上发生过吗，你还记得那种觉得自己——哦，操，这就是走向成功的感觉——的时刻吗？一路上确实有过好几个这样的时刻。我是说，主持SNL的时候，当我做那件事时，那就是其中一个时刻，因为我之前曾被那个节目解雇过，
and I was like, Oh, that's right, you were on it. Yeah, I just wanted to do it. Yeah, for four days. Yeah. Oh my God, really, for four days? Yeah, I remember seeing when they announced that you were going to host,
然后我想……哦，对哦，你以前上过那个节目。对，我当时只是想做这件事。对，就干了四天。对。天哪，真的吗，就四天？对，我记得当他们宣布你要去主持时，
and it must have been kind of surreal considering the history you had. It was, I don't know, but it was like, oh great, we're going to go through this again. There was pressure, because once they announced it, everyone's like, fuck him, don't let him back, that. And it's like, I was fine without it. I was, you know, I'm doing all right.
考虑到你过去的经历，那一定挺超现实的。确实是，我不知道，但当时的感觉就像是，哦太好了，我们又要经历一遍这个了。当时压力很大，因为一旦他们宣布了，每个人都在想：去他妈的，别让他回来，诸如此类。而我觉得，没有它我也挺好的。我当时，你知道的，我过得还不错。
But it was still awesome, and I was so happy know, I'm doing all right. But it was still awesome and I was so happy they let me back on and those people, everybody there has been, they've been awesome. But it was funny, back to the question was those moments, I was with my friend Dan Soder. He's one of the best comedians. Check him out. Super funny dude. His name's Dan Soder. I love him.
但那依然棒极了，我太高兴了……我知道，我过得还不错。但那依然棒极了，我太高兴他们让我回去了，而且那里的人，每个人都太棒了。但这就很有趣，回到刚才的问题，那些时刻，我当时和我的朋友丹·索德在一起。他是最棒的喜剧演员之一。去看看他的作品吧。超级搞笑的家伙。他叫丹·索德。我太喜欢他了。
He's unbelievably funny. Yeah. But he was like one of the first people to take me on the road. And then he and I were doing an arena. We were doing like the Cleveland Cavaliers Arena. And I was standing in the tunnel before I went out there and I looked at him and I was like, dude, I really just wanted to do a one-nighter
他搞笑得令人难以置信。对。但他其实是第一批带我去外地巡演的人之一。然后我和他在一个体育馆演出。我们在克利夫兰骑士队的球馆演出。我当时站在上台前的通道里，看着他然后说：老兄，我其实只是想去当地的喜剧俱乐部演一场单口拼盘。
at the local comedy club. I thought that was the ceiling. I don't know what the fuck this is. Hotel lobby would be nice. How I got here. Right. This has gotten out of hand. Wow.
我以为那就是我的天花板了。我不知道这他妈到底是什么情况。能有个酒店大堂就不错了。我是怎么走到这一步的。没错。这已经彻底失控了。哇。
And did you have, and so you have that moment before, and do you still have moments on stage where kind of out of body, where like you land a joke, and the place is going crazy, and you're standing, and I'm sure you're caught up in it, but you look out, and there are literally tens of thousands of people laughing
你有过……所以在上台前会有那种时刻，你在台上时是否还会有那种灵魂出窍的瞬间——比如你抛出一个梗，全场疯狂爆笑，而你站在那儿，我敢肯定你当时也身处其中，但你望向台下，那里有成千上万的人在放声大笑，
and going like, holy fuck. Usually that happens when the joke doesn't land. It's fucking 20,000 silent people and you're standing there going, oh fuck. That's much more powerful, yeah. That's a real powerful moment. Well, you know, one of the interesting things that I found in just the short amount of time
心里想着：卧槽。通常这种情况发生在你抛出的梗砸了的时候。四周是一万个他妈的安静的观众，你站在那儿心想：哦，操。那种冲击力要强得多，对吧。那才是一个真正强有力的时刻。好吧，你知道的，我发现其中一个有趣的事情是，仅仅在我短暂的经历中——
that I did it just in the small clubs over at the underground and at the cellar rather and at the one time in Austin is that, like we went one night and we were working on something and we went to the cellar in that main room downstairs and it went great. We're like, holy shit, that really worked. And then we went around the corner of the underground
就是我在地下喜剧俱乐部和（喜剧细胞）酒窖的小俱乐部里演出过那么一小段时间，还有在奥斯汀的那一次，我们有一天晚上去那里试写一些东西，我们去了酒窖楼下的那个主房间，效果好极了。我们当时想：卧槽，这招真的管用。然后我们转个弯去了地下的“地下”俱乐部（The Underground）
20 minutes later, and it was like, pretty good. It was the same material, and it was pretty good, right? It was a big room. And then we went to the fat black pussycat next door, and it was absolutely bombed. And I remember at the time, Bradley was there and my buddy Bob, who you met, and they were in the back and they were dying laughing
20分钟后，效果就变得……还算不错。用的是同样的素材，效果还行，对吧？那是个大房间。然后我们去了隔壁的“胖黑小猫”酒吧（The Fat Black Pussycat），结果彻底砸锅了。我记得当时布拉德利也在场，还有你见过的我的死党鲍勃，他们坐在后面笑得死去活来，
because literally the same material that 30 minutes ago had killed, silence. Yeah, yeah. It's the best feeling in the world watching one of your friends bomb. Nothing better. It's the most fun possible thing. But yeah, that happens.
因为明明是30分钟前还能全场炸裂的同一套素材，现在却鸦雀无声。对，对。看着你的某个朋友砸场子，绝对是世上最爽的感觉。没有比这更好的了。这是世上最有趣的体验了。但没错，这种事确实会发生。
And it happens, but what's crazy in that feeling was, which was like, oh, it's just you. There's nowhere to hide. You can't, you're just up there. You can't just go, you can't start crying and drop the microphone and run off stage. You know what I mean? You could.
确实会发生，但最疯狂的是那种感觉，也就是：哦，这全靠你自己。无处可藏。你不能……你就在台上面对这一切。你不能只是突然哭出来，然后扔下话筒跑下舞台。你知道我的意思吗？你可以的。
But talk about that, you guys. Because I think an actor can ruin a good script and they can also make a bad script good just based on performance, whether it's good performance or bad performance. Do you find that it's the same way with stand-up? Like in your case, Will, you had the same material, three different places. How much of it do you think was the audience,
但跟我们聊聊这个吧，伙计们。因为我觉得一个演员可以毁掉一个好剧本，他们也可以仅凭表演——无论是好表演还是烂表演——把一个烂剧本演好。你们觉得单口喜剧也是这样的吗？就拿你来说，威尔，同样的素材，在三个不同的地方表演。你觉得这其中有多少是观众的原因，
or was it you in the different way in which you were telling a joke? I don't have enough experience to really answer that. In that moment, I have to blame the audience just to maintain my self-esteem. But Shane, you have a lot more years of experience. I mean, what do you think it is? Like are there bulletproof jokes?
还是说是因为你讲笑话的方式有所不同？我没有足够的经验来真正回答这个问题。在那个当下，我只能怪观众，纯粹是为了维持我的自尊心。但肖恩，你有多年丰富的经验。我是说，你觉得是什么原因？难道真的有百试百灵的“防弹笑话”吗？
You know, like any, you know. There should be, and you think you have one. Like a good example, the cellar is a perfect example because it's like four different rooms. And so like I would do, there was one night I did the Village Underground, which is a great room downstairs. It's one of my favorite rooms in the country,
你知道的，无论在任何……应该有的，而且你以为自己手里就有一个。举个很好的例子，酒窖就是一个完美的例子，因为它就像是由四个完全不同的房间组成的。所以就像我会有……有天晚上我在“地下村庄”（Village Underground）演出，那是楼下一个很棒的房间。它是我在全国最喜欢的房间之一，
but I killed, I was doing, it was crazy, I couldn't believe how good it was. And then I was on next upstairs, so I literally walked off stage and walked on stage upstairs. And in your head you're like, oh, I just, you go on with the same confidence you just had from killing, where you're like,
但我当时炸场了，那感觉太疯狂了，我都无法相信效果会这么好。然后我紧接着要去楼上演出，所以我 literalmente 是刚走下这个舞台，就走上了楼上的舞台。而在你的脑子里，你会想：哦，我刚刚……你带着刚才炸场时建立的绝对自信走上台，心想：
this crowd's, wait till they fucking see this. The first joke doesn't work, and you're just immediately crushed. So it's kind of a mix of the crowd and you. You went up there kind of fucking arrogant, and then as soon as they fucking shut you down, you're like, I just shut down completely. And then at the end of my set,
这群观众，等着看他们他妈的怎么笑死吧。结果第一个笑话没响，你瞬间就心态崩溃了。所以这其实是观众和你自身状态的一种结合。你上台时带着几分他妈的傲慢，然后一旦他们他妈的不买账，你就会想：我整个人彻底垮了。然后在我表演的尾声，
I did like a fucking Trump joke and they all laughed and I was like, fuck you guys, you guys hated me this whole time. You don't get to laugh now, I hate you guys. We'll be right back. And now back to the show. Are you doing any acting at all? Have you, how's that?
我讲了个他妈的特朗普的笑话，结果他们全笑了，然后我就想：去你妈的，你们这群家伙从头到尾都在恨我。现在不许笑，我讨厌你们这群混蛋。我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。你还在演戏吗？你觉得……感觉怎么样？
Well, he's got his show, he's got a second season of his show, Tires, that he created. Oh, great. Okay, gotcha. How do you like that where the words, you've got to fit the words as opposed to the words have to fit you when you're doing standup? I don't mind it.
好，他有自己的节目，他创作的节目《轮胎》第二季也出来了。哦，太棒了。好的，明白了。当你在表演单口喜剧时，词句必须去迎合你，而不是你去迎合词句，你觉得这种感觉怎么样？我不介意。
I really like acting, especially on Tires, because that's just me and my friends, and it's all just our friends, so we can kind of fuck around, and you don't really have, you know, you can improv a little on that. Gotcha. I do have some kind of real acting coming up
我真的很喜欢演戏，特别是在《轮胎》里，因为那里面都是我和我的朋友们，全都是我们的朋友，所以我们可以随便开玩笑，而且你不会真的有，你知道的，你可以在里面稍微即兴发挥一下。明白了。我接下来确实有一些真正的演戏工作，
in a couple weeks, and I'm pretty nervous about that. We'll see how that goes. Oh, can you tell us what it is? My show's not real. I don't know if I can tell you, that. We'll see how that goes. Oh, can you tell us what it is? My show's not real. I don't know if I can tell you, so. Okay, no worries. But it's material that you haven't written and you can't improvise, so you've gotta like
就在几个星期后，我为此感到挺紧张的。我们到时候看情况吧。哦，你能告诉我们是什么吗？我的节目不是真的。我不知道我能不能告诉你这个。我们到时候看情况吧。哦，你能告诉我们是什么吗？我的节目不是真的。我不知道我能不能告诉你，所以。好吧，不用担心。但这是你没有写过的剧本，而且你不能即兴发挥，所以你必须得
study these lines, learn these lines, and play your character in such a way where it makes sense that these lines come out of that mouth, right? I mean, like, it's a different. Yes, and it's a serious director, yeah, it's scary. And it's with real actors, and that's gonna be, yeah. Oh boy.
熟读这些台词，记住这些台词，并且以某种方式扮演你的角色，让这些台词从这个嘴里说出来显得合情合理，对吧？我的意思是，这是一种不同的。是的，而且这是一个严肃的导演，是的，这很吓人。而且是和真正的演员一起，那将会是，是的。天哪。
I mean, not real actors, I'm not like shitting on my friends. But yes, you are. Yeah, you are. Yeah, yeah, yeah. And they deserve it. No, this one's real, it's not that bullshit. Yeah. Yeah.
我是说，不是真正的演员，我不是在贬低我的朋友们。但你就是在贬低。是的，你就是。是啊，是啊，是啊。而且他们罪有应得。不，这个是真的，不是那种胡扯。对。对。
What does your family think about, could you talk is your family think about? Could you talk about your family sometimes in your in your standup and you in and you're obviously really close to them? What do they what's their reaction been to all of it? Are they like caught up in the whirlwind to the are they are they freaked out? Yeah, it took them. It took them a while they Yeah, they weren't on board for a long time and then They weren't on board for a long time, especially early. I did a YouTube special, it was the first thing I put out, and in it I talk about my sister and her addiction. I talk about my sister doing heroin on a YouTube special,
你的家人对……怎么看？你能聊聊……你的家人有时会在你的单口喜剧里被提及，而且你显然跟他们非常亲近？他们对此有什么反应？他们是被卷入了这场旋风中，还是被吓坏了？是的，这花了好长时间。他们花了很长时间才接受，特别是刚开始的时候。我做了一个YouTube专场，那是我推出的第一部作品，我在里面谈到了我姐姐和她的毒瘾。我在一个YouTube专场里谈论我姐姐吸海洛因，
and she was like, what the fuck? I was like, trust me, trust me, it's going to work for us. She's just gonna hang up on me. Trust me, it's gonna pay off for me. It's gonna pay off for me. All right, oh my God. No, she got an apartment and a Chevy Cruze out of it. She's all right.
而她的反应是：搞什么鬼？我说：相信我，相信我，这会对我们有好处的。她只会挂我电话。相信我，这会给我带来回报的。这会给我带来回报的。好吧，哦天哪。不，她因此得到了一套公寓和一辆雪佛兰科鲁兹。她挺好的。
Okay, sure, sure, Chevy Cruze, there you go. How do you like life on the road? How do you like, what is that like from a social standpoint? I'm sure you're not meeting a lot of new friends out there. What's dating like and all that kind of stuff? Were you married? I'm not married. I have a girlfriend.
好吧，当然，当然，雪佛兰科鲁兹，这就对了。你觉得在路上巡演的生活怎么样？从社交角度来看，那是怎样的生活？我猜你在外面交不到很多新朋友吧。约会是什么感觉之类的？你结婚了吗？我没结婚。我有女朋友。
She lives here with me in Austin. She comes on the road sometimes. If it's like a cool venue, she'll come. Like this weekend I'm going to, tomorrow I gotta go to Knoxville, Tennessee, and then Birmingham, Alabama. So I think she's gonna sit this one out. Okay.
她和我一起住在奥斯汀。她有时会跟我去巡演。如果是个不错的场地，她就会来。比如这周末我要去，明天我要去田纳西州的诺克斯维尔，然后去阿拉巴马州的伯明翰。所以我想她这次就不去了。好吧。
But, she's not coming. How do you get your, because when you're not in the mood, you're set to go on at a certain time, it's kind of like Broadway or theater or whatever, it doesn't, you can't have a headache, you can't have a stomach ache, you can't have like, you have to go on,
但是，她不来。你是如何应对的，因为当你不在状态时，你必须在某个特定时间上台表演，这有点像百老汇或戏剧什么的，它不……你不能头疼，你不能肚子疼，你不能像……你必须上台，
you have to deliver, right? So how do you get by that? Like, how do you prepare yourself if you're not feeling? And Jason also has a follow-up question for sure. What happens when you have to take a shit depending on what you eat? Jason, we'll get to that in a second. Because if you haven't emptied, you know, you got...
你必须完成表演，对吧？那你怎么克服这个？如果你感觉不对劲，你是如何让自己做好准备的？杰森也肯定有一个后续问题。当你不得不拉屎的时候会发生什么，这取决于你吃了什么？杰森，我们一会儿就聊到这个。因为如果你没有排空，你知道，你有……
The shit goes away, right away. The adrenaline in the stand-up, the shit goes away, the headache goes away, the nausea, like, because I've done shows, a lot of the standup, the shit goes away, the headache goes away, the nausea, like, because I've done shows, a lot of shows hung over, and I've been like, oh, this is going to be terrible. And then as soon as you get on stage, it cares it. Yeah, yeah, and then interesting.
那种便意马上就消失了，立刻就消失了。单口喜剧带来的肾上腺素飙升，便意消失了，头疼消失了，恶心感也消失了，因为我做过演出，很多单口喜剧演出宿醉得很厉害，我当时想，哦，这下糟了。然后你一上台，它就好了。对，对，然后，有意思的是。
Other than one, I had one show, I did Crypto Arena in LA, and it was, I did the forum the night before, it was the best week ever. I did the Greek the night before, it was the best week ever. I did the Greek the night before, then the forum, then Crypto. It was incredible, but after the forum, I'm buddies with Post Malone and he came to the show, we're hanging out and it's like 2 a.m. after the show.
除了有一次，我有一场演出，在洛杉矶的加密网体育馆，前一晚我在论坛体育馆演，那是我经历过最棒的一周。前一晚我在希腊剧院演，那是我经历过最棒的一周。前一晚我在希腊剧院演，接着是论坛体育馆，然后是加密网体育馆。那真是不可思议，但在论坛体育馆演出后，我和波斯特·马龙是好朋友，他来看了演出，我们在演出后一直闲逛到凌晨2点左右。
I have to do Crypto in the morning, but he was like, do you want to come to my studio and listen to my new album? And I was like, yeah, definitely. So then he kept us there. We drank till like 6 a.m. And the whole time I was looking at my watch like, oh shit. So then I wake up and it's I wake up at like 4 p.m. The car is outside to take me to my next show.
我早上得去加密网体育馆演出，但他却说：你想不想去我的工作室听听我的新专辑？我说：行啊，当然。然后他把我们留在那儿。我们一直喝到早上6点左右。整个过程中我一直在看表，心想：糟了。然后我醒来时，已经是下午4点左右了。接我去下一场演出的车已经在外面了。
And I was like, all right, this this hangover will go away. I've done this a million times. The hangover just didn't go away on stage. And I kind of fucking bombed the crypto. Oh really? Oh no. Yeah, it was like the biggest show of my life. Did you let the crowd know?
当时我想：好吧，这个宿醉会过去的。这种事我经历过一百万次了。结果宿醉在舞台上就是没过去。我在加密网那场演出的表现简直一塌糊涂。哦，真的吗？哦，不会吧。对，那可以说是我人生中最大的一场演出。你让观众看出来了吗？
They could see it. There was a jumbo drum on my face. They could see it. They could smell it on the jumbo drum. They could smell light beer. So Shane, do you have anything like, you know, for endurance when you perform on stage, like do you work out, like how do you keep up your energy?
他们看出来了。我脸上有一个巨大的大屏幕。他们能看出来。他们甚至能从大屏幕上闻到味儿。他们能闻到淡啤酒的味道。所以肖恩，你在舞台上表演时有什么保持耐力的秘诀吗，比如你健身吗，你是如何保持精力的？
I just, I literally just started a trainer. I'm on week two, I got to go to that today. Good for you. Yeah, I saw some photos and I was like, all right. Oh boy. It's time to. Yeah, yeah. How do you like that, an appointment for working out? I need it, otherwise I would, you know,
我刚刚，我真的刚刚找了一个健身教练。现在是第二周，我今天还得去上课。那对你有好处。对，我看到一些照片后心想：好吧。哦天哪。是时候。对，对。你觉得这种专门预约健身的方式怎么样？我需要它，否则我就会，你知道的，
after this I would go, well that was tough, that was a long day, I'm going to take a nap. Right. Right, I'm kind of the same way. Well, Sean, Sean, I was going to say, and Shane, I'll pose it to you too, obviously diet is such a huge thing, like the things that you put in,
演完这个之后我会想，嗯，这太难了，今天真是漫长的一天，我要去睡个午觉。对。对，我也差不多是这样。嗯，肖恩，肖恩，我正想说，肖恩，我也想抛给你的问题是，显然饮食非常重要，比如你摄入的东西，
and Sean, Sean, we always say, Sean eats like he's going to a 12 year old's birthday party, every meal, every day. It's true. It's true, right Sean? Yeah, yeah, it's true. What did you have, what have you had so far today, if anything?
而且肖恩，肖恩，我们总是说，肖恩的饮食习惯就像一个去参加12岁生日派对的小孩，每顿饭，每天都这样。真的。真的，对吧肖恩？对，对，是真的。你今天到目前为止吃了什么，如果吃了什么的话？
Well, it's so funny you say that. I did have a Pop Tart, but then after, I'm just saying, I really did, but then I had a bowl, like I had yogurt with berries, because I was like, I have to balance it with something. You have to offset it. But then like, but my brain works in the way that like, well, I did that so I can have spaghetti for lunch.
好吧，你这么说太有趣了。我确实吃了一个蛋挞，但之后，我是说，我真的吃了，但我还吃了一碗，就像加了浆果的酸奶，因为我想：我得吃点东西平衡一下。你得中和一下。但随后，但我的大脑运作方式是这样的：嗯，我吃了那个，所以我午餐可以吃意大利面。
Right. Right. And do you have dessert at lunch? You do, don't you? Sometimes I do. But JB, like we'll play golf and he'll be like, hey, can I just get a couple slices of apples and a handful of nuts please? And then that's all he'll eat.
对。对。你午餐吃甜点吗？你吃对吧？有时我吃。但JB，比如我们打高尔夫球时，他会说：嘿，我能只来几片苹果和一小把坚果吗，谢谢？然后这就是他全部要吃的东西。
This is, I'm not making, I'm not even exaggerating, that's what it'll have. And I said to him one time, I said, you know what? You're doing all this, eating nuts and the thing, and you're still, you're gonna fucking die at 65 and I'm gonna be standing at your hospital bed eating a sundae with 30 years to go. You know what I mean?
这不是，我没在开玩笑，我甚至没有夸大其词，他就会吃那些。我曾经对他说过一次，我说：你知道吗？你做这一切，吃坚果和那些东西，你到65岁时还是会他妈的死掉，而我将站在你的病床前吃着圣代，离我寿终正寝还有30年。你知道我的意思吗？
But I'll look nice and thin there in the box. Jesus Christ. Jesus Christ. Oh, he died without any water weight. Look at him, beautiful. Shay, what do you think, so now you're gonna go do this serious movie with these serious actors,
但我躺在盒子里的时候看起来会很好很瘦。天哪。天哪。哦，他死的时候身上没有一点水分。看看他，多美啊。沙伊，你怎么看，所以现在你要去和这些严肃的演员一起拍这部严肃的电影了，
and again, no offense to your buddies. Hopefully, yeah. Hopefully, right. Hopefully, hopefully, hopefully. But is that for you, is that the target for you? Is that what you wanna do? Are you doing it just because you have opportunity
再说一次，没有冒犯你的朋友们的意思。希望如此，对。希望如此，对吧。希望如此，希望如此，希望如此。但对你来说，那是你的目标吗？那是你想做的事吗？你接这个只是因为有機會
and it's coming at you? Like where do you see yourself? Do you have a plan for the next five years or are you just like fuck it, whatever happens, happens? I think it's more fuck it, whatever happens. I'd like to just kind of work with my friends, kind of, if I could, the goal would probably be like the Sandler route, which is just
而且它主动找上门来？你觉得自己未来的方向在哪里？你对未来五年有什么计划，还是说你觉得去他妈的，顺其自然？我觉得更像是去他妈的，顺其自然。我只想和我的朋友们一起合作，如果可以的话，目标大概会是亚当·桑德勒路线，也就是
putting out movies with me and my friends. And then stand up, I'll always, stand up's always number one. Just stick with that. Would you consider stand up. I'll always stand ups always number one. Yeah, just with that would you consider stand up like Your job and your hobby in a way like you just love doing it when you have time Yeah, for sure people are like, yeah, that's the only thing I do really people like what do you what else do you do? It's like that's kind of it. That's it So your days are filled with maybe getting it going to the gym with it with the trainer Maybe go to the gym, a lot of Xbox, then stand up.
不断推出我和朋友们一起拍的电影。至于单口喜剧，我永远，单口喜剧永远是第一位的。就坚持这个。你会考虑单口喜剧……我永远，单口喜剧永远是第一位的。对，就坚持这个。你会把单口喜剧当作你的工作和爱好吗？就好像你有时间时就特别爱去做？对，当然。人们会说：对，这是我唯一真正做的事。人们会问：你还做什么？这就差不多了。就这些。所以你的日子大概就是健身，跟教练一起健身，可能去健身，玩很多Xbox，然后是单口喜剧。
Sure, sure, sure. Pretty pathetic. What's the current Xbox favorite? Right now, there's a game called Hell Let Loose that's pretty awesome. It's just a World War II. What's it called? Hell Let Loose. Hell Let Loose.
当然，当然，当然。挺悲哀的。目前最喜欢的Xbox游戏是什么？现在有一款游戏叫《人间地狱》，挺棒的。它就是一个二战背景的……叫什么？《人间地狱》。《人间地狱》。
Is there a headset involved with this? There is. People take it very seriously, which is pretty funny. Like guys, it's like- Are you playing multiplayer? Yeah, it's multiplayer and guys take it very seriously. It's like a World War II simulation, so there's no radar or anything. It's very funny.
这里面需要戴耳机吗？要的。大家对待它非常认真，这挺搞笑的。就像伙计们，这就像……你在玩多人游戏吗？对，这是多人游戏，大家对待它非常认真。这就像一个二战模拟器，所以里面没有雷达什么的。非常搞笑。
There's guys, you'll turn your headphone on, on guys will be like I need ammo on this hill Where are the fuck? That sounds so crazy and also how do you spell that Now the game rules who are you got who are your did did you have standup idols, Shane, or do you? Yeah, it was always Louis and Chappelle and yeah. Yeah, for sure. Was it surreal when you started doing it and then you started seeing those guys out in the world,
有那种人，你会打开耳机，里面的人会喊：我需要这个山头的弹药！到底在哪？听起来太疯狂了，另外那个词怎么拼？现在是游戏规则时间，你有哪些，你有哪些单口喜剧偶像，沙伊，还是说你……对，一直是路易斯和查佩尔，还有……对，当然。当你刚开始入行，然后看到那些人在现实中出现时，那种感觉是不是超现实，
was that surreal as hell? Yeah, now I'm like, I'm friends with both of them. It's crazy, I was just in Ohio, I was just at Dave's house two weeks ago. Wow. And he built a club and he basically owns the entire town. He does this thing where he brings in like music to this small town,
是不是超现实到极点？对，现在我觉得，我和他们俩都是朋友了。这太疯狂了，我刚去过俄亥俄州，两周前我刚去过戴夫的家。哇。他建了一个俱乐部，基本上买下了整个小镇。他会做这样一件事，他把音乐演出带到这个小镇里，
like an hour outside of Columbus, Ohio, where like, I was there a couple weeks ago and it was like Wu Tang was there. Wow, what? In a tiny 200 seat room in an old fire house. where like I was there a couple weeks ago and it was like Wu Tang was there. Wow, what? In a tiny 200 seat room in an old firehouse in Yellow Springs, Ohio. I mean it's crazy what he's doing.
比如距离俄亥俄州哥伦布市大约一个小时车程的地方，像我几周前去那儿的时候，武当帮就在那儿。哇，什么？在一个位于俄亥俄州黄泉镇老消防局里的、只有200个座位的小房间里。我的意思是，他在做的事太疯狂了。
Yeah, it's amazing. That's cool. Do you ever want to do anything like that? Like as you go on to succeed more and more? You want to do a hip hop band? I don't think I'm good enough to build a town. I do want to be in Wu-Tang. You're the best.
对，太惊人了。太酷了。你有没有想过做类似的事情？随着你越来越成功？你想组建一个嘻哈乐队吗？我觉得我没有能力建立一个城镇。不过我的确想加入武当帮。你太棒了。
I don't smoke weed, but I had to smoke blood. No, I mean, wouldn't that be cool? I mean, your star is rising so quickly and so great and so, you know, incredible that you don't do you ever aspire to be like those guys to have that kind of ability to do things like that? I think that would require a lot of longevity, and we'll see, we'll see if I have it. I think you have it, I think you have it. You're not really bullish on your future,
我不抽大麻，但我得抽……不，我是说，那不是很酷吗？我的意思是，你的名气上升得如此之快，如此之巨大，而且如此，你知道的，不可思议，你有没有渴望过像那些家伙一样，拥有那种做那种事情的能力？我觉得那需要很长时间的积累，我们走着瞧吧，看看我有没有这个本事。我觉得你有，我觉得你有。你对自己的未来并不是很乐观，
on your mortality right now. It rose too fast, and now people are gonna go, all right, that guy, the fucking Bud Light commercial guy, get him out of here. I fucking love, by the way, I love your Bud Light commercials., get him out of here. That's how it works. I fucking love, by the way, I love your Bud Light commercials. I fucking, they're hilarious. I'm not fucking joking, they're really funny.
对你目前的演艺生涯。上升得太快了，现在人们会想：行了，那家伙，那个拍百威广告的家伙，让他滚蛋吧。顺便说一句，我他妈太喜欢了，我太喜欢你的百威广告了。……让他滚蛋吧。事情就是这样的。顺便说一句，我他妈太喜欢了，我太喜欢你的百威广告了。我他妈的，它们太搞笑了。我他妈没开玩笑，它们真的很好笑。
What's the one where you're standing behind the guy and they're asking him and then you just start drinking and I'm like, this is funny. It's hard to make a funny commercial, man. It's a very short amount of time, that's a very tough medium. We know, we do it too. Yeah, and you guys did great.
你站在一个家伙身后，他们问他问题，然后你开始喝酒，那部是哪个？我觉得这很好笑。拍一个搞笑的广告很难，伙计。时间非常短，那是一个非常难搞的媒介。我们知道，我们也拍过。对，你们拍得很好。
Oh thanks, yeah. I don't know, you ever seen that dog shit one that Sean and Jason did? It was fucking terrible. Listen, you know. Which one's that? Exactly, which one's that? They've made so many dog shit commercials.
哦谢谢，对。不知道，你见过肖恩和杰森拍的那部狗屎一样的广告吗？烂透了。听着，你知道的。那是哪一部？没错，那是哪一部？他们拍了那么多狗屎一样的广告。
These guys, I love you. I love you Sean. I love you Jamie. You're such a great work partner. Oh God, you guys are the fucking worst. Shane, listen man, you're such a great dude, you're such a fucking funny dude, you've been so kind and generous to me personally,
这些家伙，我爱你们。我爱你，肖恩。我爱你，杰米。你是个绝佳的工作伙伴。哦天哪，你们俩简直烂透了。肖恩，听着，伙计，你是个绝佳的家伙，你是个太搞笑的家伙，你对我和蔼又慷慨，
so I appreciate it. Thanks for coming to do this, we wish you all the best. You got Tire Season Two, premieres June 2nd on Netflix. Uh, fifth. June, sorry. Is that right? June 5th, yeah, good for you, thank you. Sorry about that.
所以我很感激。谢谢你来参加节目，我们祝你一切顺利。《轮胎》第二季，6月2日在Netflix首播。呃，第五。6月，抱歉。是吗？6月5日，是的，祝贺你，谢谢。抱歉。
June 5th, now we got to say it a few times. So June 5th. Yeah, good for you. Thank you. Sorry about that June 5th with now we got to say it a few times Yeah, June 5th on Netflix You you're on tour right now. You're touring like internationally on fucking arenas. You got your podcast You've got a tremendous amount of success wish you continued success. Yes, you're great dude hilarious guy Shane Gillis everybody I'm a big fan big fan of all three you guys you guys are awesome. Thank you Thank you Shane back at you. Thanks for a big fan, big fan of all three of you guys. You guys are awesome. Thank you. Thank you Shane. Thanks for being here. You're a great dude.
6月5日，现在我们得多说几遍了。所以是6月5日。对，祝贺你。谢谢。抱歉，是6月5日在Netflix播出。你现在正在巡演。你在各大体育馆进行国际巡演。你有了自己的播客。你取得了巨大的成功，祝你持续成功。是的，你是个了不起的家伙，超级搞笑的家伙，各位，这是沙伊·吉利斯。我是你们三个人的超级粉丝，超级粉丝，你们太棒了。谢谢。谢谢你，沙伊，同样谢谢你。感谢你成为我们的超级粉丝，你们三个人的超级粉丝。你们太棒了。谢谢。谢谢你，沙伊。谢谢你能来。你是个了不起的家伙。
Thanks bro. Thank you. Shane Gillis. He's super fun. That guy's really funny. Yeah, he's got that real chill thing going on where it's just like, he's real, like, he's just a cool guy.
谢谢兄弟。谢谢你。沙伊·吉利斯。他超级有趣。那家伙真的很好笑。对，他有一种非常酷的松弛感，就好像，他是真实的，就像，他是个很酷的家伙。
He's really low temperature. Yeah, he is. He's really low temperature. He's really cool. Jamie, remember we watched a bunch of his beautiful dog special at New Year's. Right, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. He's got that really unique delivery
他的情绪温度真的很低。对，他是。他的情绪温度真的很低。他真的很酷。杰米，还记得我们在新年时看过他的一大堆精彩单口专场吗？对，对，对，对，对。他有那种非常独特的表演节奏，
that I find really, it pulls you into a standup where you kind of get into their rhythm. Like that's what I'm saying about Steven Wright. Like that guy just like, he's like Mike Myers in Halloween. He always walks towards the victim, never runs. Right, right, right, yeah. What a strange analogy, but you're kind of right. But he does, he pulls you in, he's great.
我发现真的很棒，它能把你的注意力吸引进单口喜剧里，让你不知不觉融入他的节奏中。就像我评价史蒂芬·赖特那样。那家伙就像《万圣节》里的迈克尔·迈尔斯。他总是走向受害者，从不奔跑。对，对，对，对。多么奇怪的比喻，但你说的有点道理。不过他确实能吸引你，他太棒了。
I mean, I've always thought he's so funny. He's like Al Pacino in Godfather 3, right? They just keep pulling you back in, you know what I mean? Godfather 3. Did they make a third one? They keep, Godfather 3? Yeah. It's a joke.
我的意思是，我一直觉得他太搞笑了。他就像《教父3》里的阿尔·帕西诺，对吧？他们总是把你拉回去，你知道我的意思吗？《教父3》。他们拍第三部了吗？他们一直在，教父3？对。这是个笑话。
What are you talking? They keep pulling you back in! I love this line! Giuseppe loved that one. I love a Godfather, now I love my foot so. Where is number four? We, we, we waiting on the number four. Cuatro.
你在说什么？他们一直在把你拉回去！我喜欢这句台词！朱塞佩很喜欢那句。我喜欢《教父》，现在我也喜欢我的脚了。第四部在哪里？我们，我们，我们在等第四部。第四。
You guys, when you talk like that, you really sound like you speak two languages. Really? Like, what would you call that? What would that make us, Sean? Bilingual. Bilingual. Bilingual. Bilingual. Smart. Less.
你们两个，当你们那样说话时，听起来真的很像会说两种语言的人。真的吗？你会怎么称呼那个？那会让我们变成什么，肖恩？双语的。双语的。双语的。双语的。聪明。无。
Smart. Less. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armjarf. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
SmartLess。SmartLess由贝内特·巴比科、迈克尔·格兰特·特里和罗布·阿尔姆贾夫100%有机手工制作。本期节目还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。